you are watching television
my head
[Music]
hi welcome to another ColdFusion video
even a decade ago the idea of browsing
online for almost any item that you
wanted and having it delivered to your
door within the same day would have been
seen as impractical and even
science-fiction but this is what Amazon
does in Europe and the United States on
a daily basis Amazon has streamlined and
perfected its internal process so much
that this science fiction has become a
reality the company hosts the sale of
350 million products in 185 countries
but that's not all from scientific
research to vast web servers the full
scale of what Amazon is involved in may
surprise you so how did this company
start and how big are they today and
what are some interesting facts about
Amazon in this video we'll explore and
find out in a proverbial Ecco to Apple's
founding Amazon was also started in a
garage though in Seattle Washington this
time and not Silicon Valley the company
was started by Jeff Bezos and the idea
first came to him while I was working at
a Wall Street firm called Essure & Co as
vice president the founder of the Wall
Street firm David Shaw had used the
Internet during his days as a professor
in the early 1990s and he saw the
potential it held for the future imagine
a world where every word ever written
every picture of a painting that every
film ever shot could be viewed instantly
in your home for an information
superhighway Bezos also saw the
potential of the internet and noticed
its rapid increase in users during
discussions between Bezos and Shore the
concept of an online store with
unlimited products came up and the idea
for Amazon was born
Bezos concluded that at first an online
store that sold everything would be
impractical he decided to narrow down
the list to 20 possible product
categories including computer software
office suppliers apparel and music the
option that seemed to fit best for a
first product was books books were the
same no matter where you bought them
from and offered diversity in terms of
choice together with his wife Mackenzie
and a start-up veteran shell Cap'n Bezos
first registered his
new idea in July 1994 is Cadabra Inc
unfortunately the name was often
misheard as cadaver Inc a company name
that could be misheard as a dead body
wasn't ideal so they decided to pick a
new one while searching for a new name
in October 1994 Bezos came across Amazon
in the dictionary
he used Amazon because it was the
largest river and mirrored his goal
becoming the biggest online retailer
globally sites were also listed
alphabetically back then and he wanted
his site to be among the first web page
as shown on November 1st 1994 amazon.com
was registered to leave a high-paying
high-profile Wall Street job to start an
Internet company in 1994 was crazy
but Jeff Bezos had a strong vision upon
beginning Amazon one of their driving
goals was to build better products than
existing online bookstores at the time
the first book was sold
April 3rd 1995 it was a computer
modeling book a few months later the
site went live and became visible to all
users of the web it opened a searchable
database of over 1 million titles even
though it only had around 2000 and stock
at the Seattle warehouse the rest would
be ordered as needed from wholesale
sellers interestingly there was no one
assigned to pack the books at Amazon at
the time so they would take orders
during the day and pack books during the
night the books would then be driven to
the post office the next morning after
being featured on the homepage of a new
site called Yahoo Amazon became swamped
with orders and within the first month
they have sold books in 45 countries in
late 1995 Amazon was granted 1 million
dollars in investment capital to expand
their business and keep up with
increasing demand through server
upgrades and the hiring of more staff
Lazos predicted 74 million dollars in
sales by the year 2000 if things went
moderately and 144 million if things
went extremely well
in actuality sales in the year 2000
amounted for 1.6 billion dollars after
receiving the investment capital Amazon
began to frantically expand
the motto back then at the time was get
big fast on May 15 1997 Amazon had its
IPO raising 54 million dollars and
valuing the company at a 438 million
Jeff Bezos had a good sense of foresight
and he predicted that the small reading
community would be the bottleneck for
their growth so they decided to move
into new products DVDs and music were
chosen between 1998 and 2000 Amazon
acquired IMDB tella butch and book pages
which gave them strategic access to
customers in the UK and the German
market during this time they also
expanded their product line to include
toys and electronics by the stage Amazon
was rapidly growing and the world took
notice this was evident by Jeff Bezos
being awarded the Person of the Year by
Time magazine in 1999 surprisingly
Amazon didn't post any profit until the
fourth quarter of 2001 where they made
five million dollars in profit Bezos
said that this was because he emphasized
customer experience over profits
financial disaster struck in the year
2001 the.com tech bubble finally burst
several the companies that Amazon had
acquired went under and Amazon stock
price dropped from a hundred and seven
dollars to a brutal seven dollars Amazon
went into crisis mode and shifted their
focus to cutting costs 1,300 employees
were laid off and a distribution
facility was shut down after some tough
times
Amazon began to recover and in 2003 they
grew their product lineup to include a
software development center Amazon Prime
and a Paris Hilton jury lion over the
next seven years Amazon would acquire a
clothing site a grocery store and would
purchase the company audio wall for 300
million dollars launched the Kindle
digital ereader and also launched Amazon
Web Services this provides many
companies with a whole range of
on-demand computing from the 2010 Amazon
will go from strength to strength
solidifying their name as one of the
tech giants
today Amazon currently employs over
240,000 employees this is over four
times the number Google how's that being
said this does include both part-time
and full-time workers during seasonal
spikes up to 80,000 additional seasonal
workers are added to deal with the
influx and sales as of January 2016 183
million unique visitors were recorded
hitting Amazon's website per month this
is the seventh largest site in terms of
traffic volume
the company has fulfillment centers or
warehouses as large as 1 million square
feet it has more than 80 of these
worldwide to get a sense of scale these
warehouses could hold more water than
10,000 Olympic swimming pools one former
employee is quoted as saying he walked
11 miles per shift or 17.7 kilometers
and 15 Amazon made 107 billion dollars
in revenue for comparison Apple made 233
billion Microsoft 85 billion and
alphabet 74 billion but when you look at
actual net income the story changes
quite a bit in 2015 amazon took in about
600 million which is very little
compared to apples 53 billion and
alphabets 16 billion as of the fourth
quarter of 2015 the retailer had more
than 304 million active customer
accounts worldwide amazingly there's
still a lot of room to grow for Amazon
currently global online retail
constitutes 7.2 percent of total retail
this is predicted to grow to eight point
eight percent in 2018 so with that out
of the way let's go a little bit deeper
how exactly do Amazon get their products
to their customers here's a short
excerpt from 60 minutes explaining
Amazon vice-president Dave Clark showed
us how the process begin after the
product arrived into the building they
are immediately scanned
the products are then placed by stackers
and what seems to outsiders as a
haphazard way a book on Buddhism and Zen
resting next to mrs. Potato Head doesn't
make any sense to me does it make sense
to you it does what because those two
things you look at how these items fit
in a bit yeah Oh optimized or utilizing
the available space of I see and we have
computers and algorithmic work that
tells people the areas of the building
that have the most space to put product
in that's coming in at that time Amazon
has become so efficient with its
stacking it can now store twice as many
goods in its centers as it did five
years ago
once your orders placed a so called pick
ambassador walks the aisles plucking and
scanning your items before placing them
in bins those bins eventually wind up in
front of a packer who knows exactly how
big of a box to use based on the weight
and amount of items your address is
slapped onto the box and then a picture
is taken of your address labels gadgets
known as shoes sort and divert the boxes
to the appropriate spiral chute based on
the postal code the boxes are then
loaded onto a waiting trucks which are
assigned to particular regions Raleigh
North Carolina in this case ok so almost
at the end of this video but what are
some cool things about Amazon some fun
facts number eight Amazon is planning to
use planes to make delivery is faster
and more efficient Amazon is taking to
the skies no we're not talking about
drones just yet the e-commerce giant on
Friday unveiled its first branded cargo
plane a Boeing 767-300 named Amazon one
it's one of 40 planes the company plans
to lease in order to speed up and
control more of its own shipping
networks so how does this play into
Amazon's larger business model why is
this important for Amazon to take more
control of its own delivery process yeah
well Amazon spends an inordinate amount
of money getting you tissue boxes toilet
paper
Amazon devices all started sorts of
stuff like that right to your door in
faster and faster time so the Mora can
actually control in that deliver
network hopefully the lower the cost
will actually be for the company what
this does give us the opportunity to do
is we will be able to run flight seven
days a week we'll be able to run a very
custom point-to-point routes today that
are optimized for our network versus a
holistic transportation network that
maybe some of our providers would
operate number seven Amazon Prime air
prime air is a future delivery system
designed to get packages safely to
consumers within 30 minutes or less
using drones these vehicles we use
obstacle avoidance technology to operate
within a safe range of 10 miles or more
prime air development centers are based
in the US UK Austria and Israel number
six with a sales record of 600 million
cells per second the delivery from
Amazon's warehouses needs to be
streamlined to help streamline the
process Amazon purchase kiva a company
that makes factory automation robots at
seven hundred and seventy five million
dollars in 2012 as of last year there
were up to thirty thousand baht not only
does Amazon plan increasing the number
it also plans on automating the process
of picking items from shelves to achieve
this Amazon set up the Amazon picking
challenge a competition where robotics
researchers compete for a $25,000 prize
to design the best pickin robot number
five Amazon Web Services Amazon Web
Services sells computer infrastructure
like storage databases and computing
power startups and more established
companies rent these in place of
high-powered servers Amazon has some
big-name clients
these include Pinterest General Electric
tinder reddit Adobe Systems Netflix
Instagram some major banks and even the
CIA
other than Netflix who else uses AWS Oh
big enterprise --is um big government
institutions like the CIA CIA does that
prevent any conflict for you the fact
that you provide the cloud that the CIA
uses for its data I don't think so
we're building what's called a private
cloud for them Charlie because they
don't want to be on the public cloud to
give you an idea of how much data some
of these clients use Dropbox at one
point was using a petabyte per day on
Amazon Web service the web server
business has generated 2.6 billion
dollars for Amazon within the first
quarter of 2016 very lucrative the
flexible inexpensive and easily
accessible web service allows thousands
of new startups to flourish and played a
large role in the transformation and
innovation of industries such as finance
health science and oil number four
Amazon's current logo has a hidden
meaning behind it
the arrow which looks like a smile is a
representation of the wide range of
available items for retail from A to Z
number three
Amazon employees spend two days every
two years working at the customer
service desk even the CEO this ensures
that every single employee understands
the customer service process
unfortunately by at least one internal
account
Amazon's relentless pursuit of customer
satisfaction often happens at the
expense of some employees making it a
difficult and unpleasant company to work
for
number two Amazon is planning to build
brick-and-mortar stores the store is is
a very rich a bunch of books because all
of them are proven bestsellers so you're
not going in that anything that you're
looking at is going to be popular it's
going to be a good read here's a couple
more little facts in 2014 Amazon
launched Amazon echo a voice-activated
assistant with his own hardware in the
same year they also required twitch a
massive online streaming platform number
one
to this day Jeff Bezos is still the
largest shareholder and currently holds
18 percent of shares he is now the fifth
richest person on earth valued at almost
70 billion dollars with some of that
money he bought himself The Washington
Post now to have one individual owner
media outlet isn't really something that
I agree with but it is what it is but
anyway back to the big picture all of
what you've just seen and heard all
began from just selling books online
it's sometimes really is crazy how
things can turn out if you go back in
time 18 years I was driving the packages
to the post office myself and we were
very primitive when I was driving the
packages myself one of my visualizations
of success is that we might one day be
big enough that we could afford a
forklift sometimes being the first to do
something and doing it better than your
competitors can be an incredibly
successful combination so anyway I hope
you learned something from that that's
the story size and some cool facts about
amazon.com thanks for watching guys give
this video a thumbs up if you liked it
subscribe to this channel if you just
stumbled across it and if you want to
see more videos about the size of
companies and how big they are how they
got started and some cool interesting
facts about them feel free to have a
browse around this channel there's
plenty of videos like that all right so
I'll catch you again soon for the next
video thanks again for watching cheers
guys have a good one cold fusion
it's me thinking
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]